If Avengers: Endgame co-directors Joe and
Anthony Russo had stuck to their original
plans for the film, The Avengers would have
encountered another past version of Captain
America, and it would have been plenty unpleasant
for him.
In a chat with Entertainment Weekly at San
Diego Comic-Con 2019, the directing duo said
they wanted Endgame to include Josh Brolin's
Thanos decapitating Chris Evans' Captain America
in 2014 to send a message to the Avengers
in the future.
After slaughtering the entire Avengers roster
in the past, the Mad Titan would have time-traveled
to the Avengers' present day in 2023, where
some of Earth's Mightiest Heroes were trying
to undo the Decimation that killed half of
all life in the universe.
Thanos would have tossed Cap's severed head
at the still-alive team's feet.
The Russos said they were almost married to
the idea.
"We clung to that story line for so long JUST
for that moment."
"He and I were fighting for that."
Joe Russo said that the idea became so deeply
set in their minds that they had a hard time
figuring out how to end the movie.
"We had most of the script working except
for the third act, because Anthony and I were
clinging to this concept."
Ultimately, though, the Russos dropped the
idea and went back to the drawing board to
see how the events of the second act could
more naturally flow into the third, which
culminated with the massive battle between
2014 Thanos and his army of alien Chitauri
against the Avengers, who were reunited with
their snapped superhero comrades.
"We couldn't give up on it, and then finally,
we said, all right, what if we don't do that?
Can we find a different way into the third
act?
And that's when it turned into what it is
now."
Avengers: Endgame screenwriters Christopher
Markus and Stephen McFeely also discussed
the intended Captain America decapitation
when they spoke with Backstory Magazine's
Jeff Goldsmith at the "Writing Avengers: Endgame"
panel on Friday, July 19.
According to Yahoo, Markus commented:
"We were working on different ways to bring
Thanos into the present day because we had
killed the present-day Thanos but we had activated
the past-Thanos.
He, being Thanos, [knew] it would take Nebula
some time to rejigger the time machine.
He went down to his present-day Earth, which
would be 2014, and wiped it out and killed
the Avengers.
And then, Nebula would turn on the time machine,
[and] he would walk through with the Avenger
he had killed and go, 'I killed you, again,
what are you gonna do about it?'"
That beheaded Avenger was, we now know, going
to be Captain America.
If America's head had rolled in Avengers:
Endgame, Marvel fans would very likely have
been horrified at the sight of their beloved
Cap's noggin tumbling around on the ground
like a soccer ball.
For our part, we're glad we didn't have to
bear witness to that specific brand of nightmare
fuel, though we can understand where the Russo
Brothers were coming from in wanting to explain
in no uncertain terms that Thanos is the most
vicious big bad the Avengers have ever encountered.
For their part, both directors brushed off
the idea that the beheading would have taken
Avengers: Endgame to too dark a place.
This twist is but one of many scenes fans
never got to see in Avengers: Endgame.
Lucky for them, the home release of the superhero
epic is fast-approaching - with the digital
version coming Tuesday, July 30 and the Blu-ray
edition arriving on Tuesday, August 13.
Both versions include special featurettes,
a gag reel, and, of course, plenty of deleted
scenes.
Since the Russo Brothers never actually went
through with the idea of Thanos lobbing off
Captain America's head in Avengers: Endgame,
that particular sequence won't be available
to watch now or ever, and it's probably for
the best.
Fans already had enough reasons to cry during
Endgame; the last thing they need is to see
Cap's A-emblazoned head at his teammates'
feet.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about the Marvel
Cinematic Universe are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.